It's a rap. Coloss.
[music]
>> For those of you guys who do not know,
Shik Luman issued out a direct challenge
to yours truly.
>> Tonight, Saturday night here in Vegas,
same masjid that you pulled up at when
there was nobody there. Mazjid N. Pull
up tonight at 7:00. I'm going to give a
talk. You're welcome to come in. You
want a debate? Come. Let's see it
tonight.
>> Now, you would assume that when someone
gives you an open invitation that
they'll welcome you with open arms,
right?
>> How you how you doing?
>> Right.
[music]
>> Somebody at the door waiting for you
guys.
>> Shake shake shake. Shakeup man told us
to come.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Shake man told us to come.
>> No no no. It's not right now.
>> Oh, okay. For sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
We'll wait. Yeah. We'll wait for him is
the uh instant panic, instant fear. Now,
I usually have this effect on the moon,
but we were invited. Now, the reasons
that they give for us not to be able to
go all the way in there, just me by
myself, no crew, no backup, no friends,
and no camera while he records. The
reason they gave is because they have
women's and children's. So, they don't
want the cameras in there. But um mom
was live streaming
kids.
>> I wanted to be with you
>> inshallah.
>> And my thing is I believe
>> okay
>> Isaam is the messenger of God. What do
you have to say?
>> Oh man, that's a shocking belief. You
know what? You convinced me. I'm with
you.
>> Okay. You see the games, all these
stipulations, all these rules, these
fake rules, all to not really debate
after you made the challenge to debate.
And so you send your middleman out and
you know, shout out to him. He was
actually pretty chill. But
unfortunately, he's getting caught in
the crossfire trying to defend you and
getting embarrassed because you made a
debate challenge and you're not stepping
up. And then they tell us that it's the
mosque rules to not bring in cameras
because the women and children. But
watch this. Listen. Listen. Um, let me
get some food.
>> My guy. My guy. So, look.
>> I love
>> So, if you if you can get some type of
confirmation within like 10 minutes at
least, but I don't mind waiting. I'll
hear. And like ask if you guys have a
problem like us recording in the masjid,
I hear you.
>> Is he Is he Which I understand. So, is
he is he willing, brother, listen. Is he
willing to come out of the maj like
right here and have a discussion? You
know,
>> I can't speak for another man, but I
will.
>> All right. Yeah, we'll wait. We'll wait
for 10 minutes.
>> Pay attention.
>> We're still waiting.
>> No, he can come in. He cannot come on
this group. So, just him.
>> Just him with no camera.
>> No camera. That's why he's asking for a
debate. So don't come ask her ask her a
question. What's what's a debate? But if
you just want views, we're not going to
give
>> drink your chai while you're
>> What's a debate?
Wh What's a debate? You mean to tell me
the same debate that you challenged me
on? The same debate that you said, "Come
700 p.m. to the masid here tonight.
Debate. Come in the mosque. Debate."
Now, now all of a sudden, y'all, we
don't know what a debate is now.
>> What's a debate? wants to meet wants to
me.
>> We don't know what a debate is. He
changed the stipulation to having an
open debate to an a Q&A where I can just
come in and ask one question. He gives
the answer and there's no back and
forth. I have to just live with the
answer. You are an absolute clown.
>> We're still waiting. Come in. He cannot
come on this group. So, just him. Just
him with no camera. No camera.
>> And notice, ladies and gentlemen, I told
you guys to pay attention. He forgot
that he had his other mic on.
[music]
>> He tried to say this undercover. He took
his mic off and when he took his mic
off, he put it to the side and tried to
whisper and talk low to the brother and
say, "Yeah, yeah, no, no. Um, yeah,
nope. Can't bring in people. Nope. No
cameras." They It was Uman's idea for me
not to have cameras in to live stream
our discussion because he did not want
to get embarrassed. It was his idea, not
the Masjid rules. He said, "No cameras."
And he said, "One qu ask question. What?
What debate?" He's asking for a debate.
What debate? All of a sudden, we don't
know what the debate is. Now, y'all,
these are the games these DA guys play.
These are the games UMAN plays. That's
why he's banned from PPD when he was
playing games and lying on PPD on that
podcast saying that the he put on false
stipulations on the Muslims. We got it
in 4K. And so for the Muslims out there
who are still fanning out, I mean, you
guys are delusional cuz that ain't just
me. I I can understand if it was just
the Christians who had a problem with
this, but even the Muslims are calling
this fake out.
the mission.
>> Henny, I'm not denying that Earth Man
knew Logic was going to record. I'm not
denying that he came.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah, bro. He ran and and and he
said and and man said that that there
will debate. Did he not say that? Like
we literally heard him say
>> I agree. W he said that. Yeah. But if he
>> Yeah, but then he changed it.
>> You can ask many questions as you want.
That implies a back and forth.
>> No, but this is this is this is Hold on.
Hold on, guys. This is what's going to
happen. This is exactly what happened.
Isa um logic will go in there ask his
his question that is oh ask questions
he's going to ask him okay in this verse
it says this he's going to give an
explanation and then and then logic
about okay and then he's like no no no
now it's the next question I told you
you're going to ask a question I'll
answer it and then that's your response
you either like it or you don't scene
you you don't know what was going to
happen
>> no but based off we how we see him
debate that's how man debates broman
isn't a good
hold up hold up everybody Everybody
Everybody in the chat knows it too. I I
>> Yeah, but but you don't Okay, so we seen
that on his live. We seen on his live
when he was
>> Yeah, but we but we seen we seen him do
that though.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. One question he answers and he
just says next question.
>> It's how it's how we recognize P. Yeah.
Like exactly what Dub said pattern
recognition. Like it's a pattern that he
does.
>> Dub is a Catholic Christian. Dub
>> Dub is a is a Muslim. What are you
talking about?
>> No, no, no, it's not.
>> Doug is Dub is Muslim,
>> bro. that I must there's there's
definitely a Christian dub there is
>> no doub is a
>> no but regards I mean there there's
nothing wrong with saying like man is
not like a cuz even having a question
that's completely one-sided I just I
loathe
>> but wait but one second but earth man
and logic have been speaking for it's
not like this is their first discussion
broman knows what logic is like logic
knows what man is like logic obviously
man doing it this way hold up yo yo mr
everything mr everything shut your ass
up bro he literally said to come debate
what are you talking about uh uh what do
you mean logic? No, he told him to come
debate. He came to debate. He didn't
want to debate. Like are we going to be
like dumb guys?
>> Are y'all going to act like
>> My bad. You're you're you're Muslim. My
bad.
>> Are you guys an act are you guys going
to act like like like brain dead
followers? Like zombies like man like
fanboys? Like come on.
>> Like no we call we call it for what it
is, man.
>> That's why focus.
>> That's why we got to have That's why we
got have Libbyiano belt this guy. No. No
one. We got to get Liiano cuz man ain't
belting him. be honest.
[laughter]
>> Wow. We need Libyano. Liiano needs to
come save the day. But unfortunately for
Libyano, uh I've already destroyed him
twice. He already admitted that Jesus is
Yahweh and alleged sins and is the most
high in a sense while trying to argue
that Jesus isn't the most high. And uh
we had another debate on his own channel
where I hopped on his on his uh stream
and even his own Muslim brothers, his
teachers tell him that he got packed out
in that discussion. Jake, what's up?
What's up with you, bro? What's up with
the with the tweets, man? Libyanna, like
what's that about? Like, don't you think
it's a little like inappropriate
to go and say that like publicly?
>> Nah, he got packed out. It's all good,
though.
>> When you say he got baked, baked about
what exactly? He got baked in his
conversation with God Logic when they
were talking about essential hypoatic
properties. And I tried to tell him
privately, but he didn't want to listen
and take the advice. Gave me the shoe
shoe fly away. And then some other stuff
happened behind the scenes. So then now
eventually I'm just going to say how I
feel.
>> Oh, so okay. So it's not a dean matter
then. It's more of a personal matter.
>> No, it is a dean matter. That's fine.
>> No, it's not. Cuz you just said it,
Jake. You just said that. Well, you you
address him privately and so so actually
let me ask you this. So you believe
>> that logic was right that there are
hypoatic necessary properties.
>> Yeah. And anyone who doesn't know that
is stupid.
>> I know I I think that you would agree
that you know there are essential
hypoatic properties, right?
>> No, I wouldn't agree.
>> That's why they need to stop jocking my
style if they can't run with it.
>> Okay, that's fine.
>> So you you hit him up and he didn't
accept what you what you were trying to
give him and
>> Yeah. So, if you didn't accept it, my
brother, you don't know this. I had
literally like a I don't even want to
say a dozen, but a handful a handful of
DMs from people who had Schuba hat from
that discussion who
>> because they must have did a little bit
of research, a Google search with which
Liiano, I guess, didn't do. And they
find out, no, actually what Liiano is
saying doesn't really make sense. What
Logic is saying is correct. And now they
got Shoua Hat and they're messaging me.
So that's private. Then I respond to the
person privately. I tell them, "No,
sorry, brother. Yes, Lana was wrong
about that. Here's the deal. Here's the
proof." Blah blah blah. The guy goes to
Discord, puts it in their Discord, and
then they come to me buttth hurt. Jake,
why did you say this to the guy? Well,
he messaged me cuz he got a sha because
you of your failure in the debate. Now
he went with my answer back to your
Discord server and you're mad at me. So,
this is what I'm telling you, bro. This
is not like some small thing. Oh, he
just made a mistake and Jake is just
blowing it up. And it's many layers to
this. I told him he was wrong. He didn't
want to take the advice. I had people
messaging me. I told them the truth of
what it really was. It went back to
their Discord server. They were buttth
hurt by it. And now it's come full
circle. Wow.
Incredible.
You see that Libyano can't save you.
Shikman, he failed. Libyano according to
his own teachers, he failed. He failed
so bad that Muslims were getting
shouahhat meaning doubts. They were
getting doubts because of our
conversation that we had because they
simply did a simple search and found out
that logic was right again and Liviana
was dead wrong and they had doubts about
their own religion. Beautiful stuff. But
wait, there's more. When we take it to
Twitter, there were other Muslims that
were digging it into Uman and not in the
Alz sense. So, this is from a Muslim on
Twitter named Knowledge North. And this
is what he has to say. The one positive
in all this is that no Muslim will feel
anything but disgust and revulsion for
this new breed of aggressive bad faith
quote unquote Christian. No one with a
even a halfbrain is going to fall for
the Jesus loves you get out of jail
copout after watching an evangelist
harass and provoke a non-Christian who
was just trying to mind his own business
and this is part it gets good after all
that boo it says here however Abu Kub
live that's Shikman's uh channel and his
sky fanatic Abu Katub fan base so the
Shikman fan base are responsible for
this freak show. Uh-oh. When you spend
your time childlessly
taunting people, we're calling you out.
You're running. What exactly did you
think you were inviting? Tea and
biscuits. If you are, if you actually
want to challenge someone to a debate,
then freaking get it done. Stop the
playground nonsense. Hakikachu and Jake
the metaphysician, they the both of them
whom you know despite hating each other
and deservably can still sit down and
slug it out in a verbal joust because
that's what grown men do when they're
serious. And they've both already done
moderated debates with the exact same
Christian cohort you keep pretending is
scared of you. So spare us the BS.
You're no better than the Islamophobes
when it comes to drama, clout chasing,
and clickbait. [snorts]
This isn't da. This ain't Islam you're
serving. This is your ego and playing to
your illdeserved self-appointed shake
status.
And the worst part, the poor brother
featured in God Logic's video got
dragged into your mess. He was insulted,
harassed, cornered, and pushed into
saying things he may regret or that or
that could land him in trouble because
you poke the bear, whip up the crowd,
then disappear while someone else deals
with the fallout. You give the devil a
means against the innocent every time
you play your dumb YouTube games. enough
for Allah's sake. Either man up or grow
up. No one is running from you. Clearly,
while you're while you are running the
reputation of Muslims into the ground
and whatever integrity you've got left
is going down with it. But wait, there's
more. From brother Haj, I agree with
you. Same thread. This charlatan named
quote unquote Shik Usman Khan has a case
of self-grande that really ought to be
examined scientifically as it has
baffled anyone with a with half a brain.
I would never support a disbeliever over
a believer. However, ever since I saw
the video where he used a footnote and
was embarrassingly called out for it,
his behavior has been indefensible.
The response from this so-called shake
showed that even if the truth were to
hit him square in the face, he still
would not admit he was wrong. The level
of his knowledge is superficial at best
and his claim of holding a master's
degree in hadith is laughable.
I already know that he paid others to
write his book on the turban. He is a
liability.
While we support Imman over Kufur, we
cannot ignore the red flags. This man is
a poor representation and has used da to
benefit himself. The DA scene has become
a complete joke. But wait, there's more.
Jake the Muslim metaphysician with a
comment that says, "Agreed. I tried to
keep my mouth shut, but at this point,
the amount of pump faking by UMAN is
pathetic.
You are certainly not required to debate
God logic or any of these people.
However, if you seriously wanted to, you
could easily make it happen. Live
streams with thumbnails appearing as if
a debate is going to happen when both
sides knew it wasn't is beyond corny by
now. Grow up already.
Oh. [screaming]
This stuff is just sad at this point.
There's probably something really wrong
with Uman like up there. He's probably
not all the way there up in his head.
Uh, which is why we see the antics.
Maybe he believes the stuff that he
says, maybe he doesn't. Who knows? But
man, you are you are a weirdo and you
are a coward. You are a clown.
Christians are calling you out. We see
it. Your Muslim brothers and sisters are
calling you out and they see it. And so,
you got to do some self-reflection, man.
You cannot be faking the funk out here
for too long cuz eventually it's going
to be exposed and you're going to die
out. Of course, you're going to have
your brain dead fans that are going to
cling to you, but only for so long. Your
channel's dying out. You need us for
content. You needed us for this little
spark. But I'm done with you, man. I'm
done with you. You played enough games.
I showed up. You didn't show up. You
were too scared. All the footage is out.
All the proof is there. So, don't ever
call me out again. Don't ever mention my
name. Don't call out David Wood. Don't
you dare call out Inspiring Philosophy.
Don't call out Sam Shimone. Don't call
out any of us cuz we answered. I pulled
up and all in all, don't ever say this
again.